aujourd'hui je vous parle de sac c'est
une vidéo qui réalise en partenariat
avec la marque vie qu'elle propose un
produit très intéressant ça connectés
sac intelligent je vais les mettre
dehors au pire oui ça va tu es enfant tu
perds tu t'es bien coiffé pour être sur
la vidéo beau gosse comme ça tout laisse
bosser les gars alors je vous montre
c'est un sac connectés de la société vie
quelle société française qui il fait
plein d'objets coup de la maroquinerie
toussa toussa toussa et qui nous propose
un nouveau sac intelligent c'est le sac
il s'est pas sac à dos comme les autres
c'est un sac à dos qui va pouvoir vous
solutionner pas mal de problèmes est-ce
qu'il vous est déjà arrivé lorsque vous
étiez dans le métro le tram le bus ou
compagnie que quelqu'un vienne ouvrir
votre sacoche se sert dans votre sac
bien évidemment sans vous puissiez le
savoir faire avec vos affaires
ça c'est le premier problème deuxième
problème est ce qu'il vous est déjà
arrivé de partir d'un endroit quels
qu'ils soient
en ayant oublié votre sac si vous vous
retrouvez dans les deux cas et bien ce
sac là très clairement est fait pour
vous vous êtes peut être
q vous êtes dans les transports en
commun dans le métro dans le tramway
dans ce que vous voulez vous attendez et
derrière il ya un vilain voleurs cqp
reyel qui va venir vraiment sac voilà je
suis là c'est une guerrière et là ça se
met à queen est juste là celle arrêtée à
temps mais j'ai entendu ce que je fais
c'est que je saute dessus et je me vois
donc j'appelle la police lui la peur et
moi j'ai l'information
donc ça c'est cool en fait le système
est hyper simple on prend on ouvre à
peine sabip ça couine genre ferme c'est
fini donc s'il vaut leur duo pas pardon
tout conseil j'ai pas voulu voler sur
une petite erreur il referme très c'est
assez dissuasif c'est intéressant parce
que ça arrive directement dans votre
smartphone et en plus c'est vraiment
fort ce qui fait que même si vous avez
des écouteurs vous avez un petit casque
ya beaucoup de bruit vous entendez quand
même parce que le petit bip qui a dans
le sac
vous entendrez pas mais par contre le
smartphone qui hurle ça vous l'entendrez
et autant vous dire que à mon avis ça va
vous donner l'alerté et ça va faire
partir la personne donc ça c'est kad
usage numéro un c'est vraiment
intéressant cas d'usagé numéro 2 vous
êtes par exemple au bureau comme ici
vous avez posé votre sac et puis le soir
de reporter du travail et pensait pas
forcément à prendre notre sac avec lui
ça peut arriver des plaintes ou rooney
tête en l'air après une grosse journée
de travail dé fond d'oublier un peu les
choses
vous repartez tranquillement au bout de
quinze mètres une limite de 15 m vous
allez recevoir une notification sur
votre smartphone ça va sonner sa
d'habiter ça vous dit ah vous avez
oublié un truc
vous avez oublié votre sac du coup vous
faites demi-tour vous le récupériez ça
c'est le deuxième cas d'usagé moyenne
soleil qui vient c'est de me sauver un
peu la rétine troisième point qui est
intéressante si vous avez oublié votre
sac que vous avez désactivé l'alarmé que
vous êtes quand même parti et bien ce
qui est intéressant c'est que il va
enregistrer la dernière position du sac
connu parce que vous avez de la
géolocalisation ça vous l'indiquer sur
une carte dont vous saurez à quel
endroit
votre sac a été connecté pour la
dernière fois avec votre smartphone
comment ça marche tout seul vous avez
votre 5 vous avez à l'intérieur une
petite poche ou débarquer genuis object
parce que dieu nous sommes gect c'est
une start up qui vient de bordeaux qui
travaille avec vigueur sur ce projet
vous avez donc un spécialiste de la
maroquinerie et du sac qui fabrique des
supers saxe vous avez là tout est une
start-up bordelaise qui est spécialisée
dans where hebel dans l'objet connectés
qui justement vous faire un produit qui
est très sympa alors vous avez ici à
l'intérieur petite carte avec un circuit
imprimé une pile que vous pouvez venir
changer si vous voulez qui va se
connecter directement à votre fermeture
et qui va reconnaître l'ouverture et la
fermeture vous avez la fermeture zip ngô
thoi cali lui trois ans de recherche et
développement etc en outre à peine là ça
marche directement ces actifs
directement c'est cool je pense que
c'est que dès qu'on arrive là en fait à
cette petite partie c'est là vous avez
les les connecteurs je passe ouais voyez
c'est ça
là vous avez ici le constat qui fait
danser donne alors à moins que vous ayez
un voleur avec des doigts extrêmement
agile et très fascinant ils en feront
absolument rien voilà ça sert
directement donc fermeture zippée ngo
vous avez donc une fermeture qui est
complètement connecté liés à votre
smartphone le truc pour réparer tout con
mais c'est vraiment bien alors après on
pourrait se dire que le seul moyen de
passer à travers ça c'est que vous ayez
un mec qui arrive avec un couteau et qu
il use comme ça je pense quand même que
dans le métro c'est un petit peu ma
pratique un peu mort à pipi au couvent
où le sentir y est la méthode la plus
simple reste quand même joue je prends
je me sers il ya des mecs ils sont quand
même spécialisés les noix le parisien
clément fait rosser dans le cerveau les
dans ton sac là vous avez une
application c'est l'application jenas
objects vous la montrer dans quelques
instants vous allez voir comment ça
marche là vous autorisez
le modjo la collection bhutto sinon ça
marche quand même relativement pas c'est
un peu compliqué vous autorisez en plus
la localisation la géolocalisation dans
l'application se permettra de
géolocaliser votre sac le sac en lui
même est franchement cool
vous avez une poignée qui est hyper
confort de leur espèce de mousse très
facile à attraper bon derrière c'est
pareil bandoulière fournir la tâche y
est c'est pratique c'est sympa mais
petit logo is it comme ça qui est très
jolie son côté une petite poche qu'on
irait imploser votre bouteille ou tout
ce que vous voulez à une poche secrète à
l'arrière coller directement dans votre
dos parce que celle là elle n'est pas
connectée donc vous êtes peut être vos
papiers d'identité tout ce que vous
voulez c'est bien là vous avez une de
quoi la tâche est directement à une
valise
lorsque vous voyagez ça je le fais tout
le temps lorsque je pars en voyage je le
prends c'est vraiment très pratique
à l'intérieur vous avez quand même de la
place va vous avez une poche comme qui
suffisamment grande ou deuxième poche un
scratch situé à l'avant qui va quand
même assez loin assez profond pour
mettre un peu de bazar gym et du train
truc histoire de vous montrer
smartphones
mon casque donc là on est une poste
quand même vachement grande
on a beaucoup de volume on peut mettre
pas mal de choses dedans une deuxième
petite moche comme un des documents et
là j'ai mis mon ordinateur macbook pro
15 pouces qui tient parfaitement bien
sans galère avec un côté matelassé pour
venir renforcer et protéger le
l'ordinateur c'est pareil à un haut
niveau de l'arrière c'est c'est ma
classe et ses protégés face à face
ensemble à pain un textile respirant je
pense pour la transpiration ou est quand
même en mettre le sac et grands sympa
j'aime bien moi cette couleur comme ça
c'est bleu qu'on a des petits liseret
oscillant rappel pour le retrouver à
l'arrière
ici je trouve très sympa d'un point de
vue design vous avez le logo sur l'avant
lisible d'ailleurs si vous êtes des
voleurs et vous voyez ça c'est pas la
peine de vous approcher de mon sac est
en dessous à une poche caché qui est
juste là qui va vous servir en cas de
pluie alors déjà le sac comme ça il est
quand même relativement étanche mais ils
vous donnent une petite couche de
protection je voulais mettre dessus
toutefois vous avez beaucoup trop de
pluie vous êtes sous une
la grêle sous une averse vous venez vous
le protéger je vais quand même le mettre
sur votre dos ça pour le coup c'est la
première fois que je vois ça alors j'ai
pas vu tous les sacs du marché mais je
trouve ça quand même relativement
intéressante ça c'est l'application
janos object et une petite inscription
qui est très très rapide vous rentrez
votre email un mot de passe pas plus
c'est vraiment hyper facile et à vous
avez accès à votre tableau de bord dont
vous voyez là mon sac est fermé tiens un
petit bouton la regarde et je peux
appuyer
j'entendais ya le sac est juste à côté
ça m'a fait bip et ça je peux voir
rapidement oui il l'est j'ai mes
réglages là ne pas déranger of donc
c'est bon grands pouvaient me dérangeait
sécurité renforcée j'ai tous les bits
toutes les notifications à feu vers un
mode discret ce que veut dire
personnaliser un petit peu en fonction
de ce que je veux ce n'est réglé aussi
la sonnerie pour les notifications je
peux nommer mon sac
ce que m une pause d activation de
temporaire situé dans un endroit qui est
pas une zone que j'ai paramétrer comme
une zone sécurisée mais que je veux pas
qu'ils bip
je peux bien le faire bon supprimé mon
sac si toutefois je veux plus du tout
l'utiliser et lorsque je joue vraiment
ça qu'à côté attention jeu lourd hop là
voyez j'ai eu notification j'ai le bruit
ces pratiques il a toujours un ferme
immédiatement ça le reconnaît
directement ça communique très très très
vite l'a ensuite fait à créer des zones
de confiance lorsque par exemple vous
êtes chez vous vous êtes au bureau vous
êtes où vous voulez je suis exactement
ici dans paris et ça c'est ma zone de
confiance alors effectivement c'est
quand même relativement grand sur 100 m
dites vous bien que c'est vraiment
lorsque vous allez être chez vous
lorsque vous allez être au bureau ou
dans une salle de sport ou mais dès que
vous allez partir forcément sortir un
peu de la scène house on a bipé là mon
sac est fermé je mets à côté je louvre
tout va bien ils ne sonnent pas ça c'est
pratique par contre dès lors se sortir
de la zone de confiance qui va me payer
là vous le voyez il l'a reconnu zone de
confiance donc maintenant je suis chez
moi je l'ouvrir je peux m'écarter est
absolument aucun problème si ce produit
vous intéresse il ya une campagne hull
en ce moment et jusqu'au 28 juin 2019
vous invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil parce que je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant
vous aimez le lien en bas d'aller script
sion vous pouvez y aller vous êtes
toutes les informations formations
complémentaires sur le sac sur ce que
vous pouvez faire lire des photos des
vidéos ou 26 vachement intéressant vous
avez donc une campagne de crowfunding 2
financement participatif
l'idée en fait c'est que vous aller
commander votre sac à tarif préférentiel
pour les 150 premières précommandes vous
l'avez à -24% ça coûtera 99 au lieu de
129 euros et ensuite à vous fait moins
15% à 109 euros au lieu de 129
et puis si vous voulez acheter à 2
prouve votre pote votre compagne qui
vous voulez ça vous le sort à 199 au
lieu de 250 8 c
beaucoup avec une livraison estimé au
mois de novembre 2019
ce qui tombe plutôt bien parce que moi
novembre 2009 c'est le moi de mon
anniversaire je dis ça jeunes derrière
si ça vous botte vous avez le lien en
bas dans la description en tout cas
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant parce
qu'il sait par un sac à dos en plus
c'est pas juste un sac à représenter il
a une vraie belle fonctionnalités hilali
lie aux ti le textile on va dans le web
sommes très clairement dans le l'objet
connectés on a un partenariat
intéressant entre vie qu'elle jenny
s'objecte c'est cool ça vous fait un
objet qui est beau qui est sécurisé et
puis surtout solutionne un problème en
soi et ça va beaucoup mieux dit pas ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous êtes déjà
fait voler des affaires dans votre sac
métros trams transports en commun dans
la rue pourquoi pas ça arrive notamment
à paris et quand même beaucoup de
pickpockets mais c'est pas forcément un
problème que parisiens donc ça intéresse
beaucoup de monde sera solutionné
beaucoup de problèmes et puis surtout le
fait et c'est un tout je pense aux
étourdis ça il y en a absolument de
partout qui oublient leurs sacs et
disent merde qu'est ce que j'en ai fait
ou est ce qu'il est là dès lors qu'il
est déconnecté vous le voyez sur un plan
vous voyez il est brouillé sa dernière
position ça c'est vraiment cool tu sais
pas tout ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire je vous invite à aller faire
un petit tour pour découvrir ce projet
ulule je trouve intéressant et si vous
botte
n'hésitez pas à le pré commander vous
avez un tarif vraiment très intéressant
jusqu'au 29 juin voilà nous embrasse à
bientôt ciao